and is brought to you today by your
cable or satellite provider
in an interview from 1997 the late
publisher of the washington post
katherine graham talks about her book
personal history it's an autobiography
on the history of the washington post
other topics include the watergate
scandal the pentagon papers and a
journalist strike
katherine graham author of personal
history
did your children learn anything from
this book about you
that's a hard question i'm sure they
probably did but i couldn't tell you
exactly what
all
stuff in here about your early life and
your husband and all that did they know
that if you all talk that out
yes i think they understand
that he was ill
the oldest one was 20
and the youngest one was 11.
so they had to deal with it then and
always
the question i had after i read the book
was why do you want us to know all this
i really don't suppose that i meant to
just tell everything to everybody but
once i sat down to write my story
i just tend to be frank and open
and i wanted to be very truthful and i
just wrote it the way i saw it and the
way the research came up with
i told it as i the best i could when did
you start it
about six and a half years ago i started
to do the research for this book i
actually had the idea even longer ago
than that
you addressed earlier in the book that
you wrote it yourself
i did
but i also had very good assistance from
a fine researcher evelyn small and my
editor at knopf bob gottlieb
so i consider that i had assistance from
them but i wrote the words myself right
how did you go about it
well first we for about two years we did
research because i had no diaries
so
we looked up all the letters and luckily
i grew up in a day when you all wrote
letters
all the time
and so we had a lot of those and we had
memos from the post from phil's day from
my day
and we had a lot of paper that i didn't
know we had and that helped a lot
um and
then we did 250 or more or less
interviews with my contemporaries
starting with schoolmates and working on
up to politicians and judges and
other people that we dealt with and that
helped fill in the record
what year did your father buy the post
in 1933 he had just gotten out of the
government and been out about three
weeks as he'd been governor of the
federal reserve board and he had started
the reconstruction finance corporation
under hoover and he stayed as federal
reserve chairman for a little while
under roosevelt and then he resigned
because he didn't like roosevelt's
monetary policies and went to mount
kisco
the post came up three weeks later
for auction on the steps of the building
and he bought it anonymously
what do you pay for it
eight hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars how many newspapers were there
in washington then
there were five and and the post was
fifth
in a field of five
and so
it had about circulation of fifty
thousand in a pretty broken down
building
and um
so he started in and he thought he was a
businessman and he thought he knew how
to turn around businesses but he really
had never had any newspaper experience
and he encountered the most horrendous
difficulties in fighting his way up but
he really did a terrific job starting
with nothing
where's mount kisco
mount kisco
where they lived in the summer
uh was about an hour it was about
50 miles from new york city in
westchester county
and we went there every summer and they
had built this large house there
thinking that my father was going to
live there when he was on wall street
and was going to commute to wall street
but it just got built when we moved to
washington where they moved to
washington
when did your father meet your mother
in 1912
they met in a museum
in
new york city my father
had picked up a friend and they were
driving downtown
in an old car that he had called a
stanley steamer
and he picked up this friend whom he
didn't either know very well or liked
very much
and said that he would like to give him
a ride but he was going to stop off at a
japanese print show
and they did that and they saw my mother
walking around in the show and my father
said to his friend that's the woman i'm
going to marry
and
so the friend said
well then you have to speak to her my
father said no no that would spoil
everything one of us is going to meet
her and
whoever meets her first will call the
other one and about two weeks later
the friend called my father and said
guess what
and he said you've met the girl
and he said damn you i have and i've
arranged that we're all gonna have
dinner
and from that for two years that was on
lincoln's birthday
and they were married two years later on
lincoln's birthday now what impact has
it had on your life that he was jewish
and she was lutheran
a quite weird one actually
neither one of them i have to say were
very religious
my mother may be a little more than my
father
he had at the age of 14 or
studied for
a bar mitzvah
and then he decided he said i believe
some of that but not all of it and i'm
not going to do that
and he never he was very very ethical
very driven very
moral but he wasn't
formally religious
um
she neither was she but her family was
and his family was
and so um she took us to church and
but very
not very formally
but as you grew older i mean from time
to time you see in the book where
anti-semitism came into your life how
often
well almost not at all strangely when i
was young a couple of times
one was when i was in school and
somebody was casting
the merchant of venice
and said maybe i should play [ __ ]
because i was jewish and i didn't have
any idea that i was or that there was
such a thing i knew nothing about it and
at some other point they'd said my
father was a millionaire and i didn't
know what either one of them meant so
i'd gone home
asked my mother what what it meant to be
jewish and what it meant to be a
millionaire
and i don't think i got any explanation
for either one at that point but then
later in college it came up because of
course hitler started and it was more of
an issue but i spent my whole youth
bizarrely unaware of the issues or of
anti-semitism or of anything
i mean i should have pre known a lot
more about it i should have
um
known both their heritages and what it
meant to be jewish what it meant to be
lutheran but it simply wasn't mentioned
not
by the way i'm sure they weren't ashamed
or worried about it it just
was that nothing intimate was really
talked about in my family how many other
kids in the family there are five of us
in all and i was the fourth
how many are still alive
i have two sisters one older my sister
elizabeth lawrence and one younger my
sister ruth epstein
she was four years younger than me and
there were two years between all the
rest of us
and you grew up where
and why well we we spent our first years
in new york and that's kind of a strange
part of the story because my family had
moved to washington
but they were there for almost four
years before they moved us down to
washington so we were living mostly with
governances and nurses and music
teachers and things like that in the new
york apartment
and then in fact they'd come up in
between and visited us and occasionally
my sisters would go down to washington
but i was a baby
and
when i was four we all moved to
washington
where'd you go to college
i went for two years to vassar and for
two years to the university of chicago i
changed
and a fellow named mortimer adler
i see taught you
well there was a chorus taught by
mortimer adler and robert maynard
hutchins together the president of the
university
and it was the history the i'd great
ideas in the western world they thought
that
hutchins had a theory that
i think started
at st john's college in annapolis
that if you learned the great ideas of
the western world
that that would be your education and so
this course
started with plato and aristotle and
worked all the way up to
saint through saint thomas aquinas and
to freud and marx
and
they drilled you there was a socratic
method
and you had to kind of stand up for
yourself and defend your ideas to them
and it was very rigorous training and i
really liked it but it was very hard
who became your favorite philosopher out
of that
anybody
i think i liked the greeks i liked
aristotle and plato talking about
happiness and the ends of life and what
you thought about
i was really interested in that
after college what
well i had
proudly gone off and gotten myself a job
at the university of chicago
um i mean i'd use my
my law prof my
labor relations professor paul douglas
who later became a senator
knew the publisher of the then chicago
times the afternoon tabloid
and
i went down there and asked him for a
job
and he said he would take me but if i
wasn't any good then i shouldn't think
he was going to keep me and i said that
would be fine i'd love a try out
then i went home and my father asked me
to go out to san francisco with him on a
train trip he was taking because he was
going to the bohemian grove at all men's
reserve
and i said fine i'd never seen san
francisco
and i stayed there while he was at the
bohemian grove
and he
came back and i said i love this town
and if i will swallow my pride give up
my job in chicago will you help me find
a job here and he did
and you met harry bridges
well i covered
a
long shoreman's
labor dispute it was a lockout
on
the whole waterfront of everybody who
was working in the warehouses
it was after two years after the very
bloody well-known longshoreman stripe
and
i
was asked by the labor reporter to do
the legwork on this
and i went up and down the waterfront
and got to know
the negotiator for the union sam cagle
and the head of the warehousements union
jean patton
and occasionally harry bridges and i
have to say
although it isn't correct these days i
socialized with them at night and we
went up and down the waterfront
drinking what is known as boilermakers
and they were willa makers i fear they
were whiskey
whiskey and beer mixed and you could get
three of them you could get a third one
free if you paid 25 cents for the first
two
about
80 pages in you say my political outlook
developed further as a committed liberal
primarily passionate
anti-fascist and sympathetic toward the
labor movement
still there
honestly not i mean i am in that
you deal
and want to deal
with organized labor
and we do
but i think that
as it was then they were just getting
organized and the the industrial unions
were all new the steel and um
miners
uh were were unorganized and they were
just getting organized and so their
situat their
labor conditions
were quite bad
uh
right now
some of the unions are fine and needed
just the way they are and some like many
businesses
i feel have gotten into
practices that are not particularly
constructive and
that have to be rethought like feather
betting when it's not needed
and after all these years what what's
your political philosophy today how
would you define yourself
i think i'm just about where i was
i i'm centrist
probably more democratic than
not but i'm independent i've voted for
for republicans as well as democrats but
i feel strongly about issues of racial
justice and poverty in cities and
i feel strongly that
there has to be something done
within the context of our of of the way
this country is
and uh i'm obviously committed to all
the values such as freedom of speech and
and the things that
i feel that
enlightened semi-liberals
are for i think people be surprised to
find out you voted for george bush in
1988
i suppose so because i think the most
surprised person would probably be
president bush why do you think he'd be
surprised
well i think that most presidents get
sensitive about the post and newsweek as
well
and they
he had his issues with us but i think
any president does
but i
i suspect he would not think i'd voted
for him
give us a just a thumbnail sketch of the
post company today how many newspapers
television stations how big is it what's
the gross revenues on a year's basis
uh we're at about a billion six
in annual revenues
and
the company
holds
mainly the washington post
and
we have a small newspaper the emerald
everett herald and half of the
international herald tribune
and then we have newsweek and we have
six television stations
and
a million and a half cable connections
and we also have digital inc
which is our electronic
media and a washington post website are
you still chairman of the executive
committee no
oh yes i am chairman of the executive
committee i thought you were going to
say chairman i know i am chairman of the
executive committee and how long were
you chairman of the washington post
company
30 years
go back to
that's
a little bit
average but go back to san francisco
then you come back to washington when
was your first job at the post
in nineteen
well actually i worked there summers in
college i mean after school but after
school um
in 1939 when my father came out and
suggested that i come back from san
francisco and work on the post
and i was it was time for me to leave
there in many ways and i was happy to do
that what was your job
it was
low person on the editorial page
um i edited letters to the editor i made
up the page
and i wrote a few
editorials of no great moment
when did you meet phil graham that year
that i came back
i was really surprised because when i'd
left washington
to go to college
it was still a very republican town
and
it was kind of stuffy you know there
were parties
of um
my parents age and then our parties were
kind of dances and
their third generation real estate
and when i got back the new deal had
come and grown up and it was pre-war
and and the town was just full of
attractive young men
and it was not the town i remembered and
i was simply thrilled
and how did you meet him
i met him
in a house where i got to know some of
the people two of the people who worked
on the post were living there
and there were 12 bachelors in this
house
and he was one of the 12 and i didn't
meet him until
he was going out with some other women
girls
and
i actually met him one night when we'd
all gone to a restaurant and were coming
back
and i they were living at s street they
hadn't moved to arlington which they
later did
and i leaned out the window with a lot
of other people because the tail end of
the party was coming in and i
unfortunately the screen fell out onto
his head
and he was startled and looked up
and we i looked at him and in fact i met
a girl that night when i went to the
bathroom
and
i she said she went to law school and i
said how
marvelous i could never do that tell me
about it how do you do it and she said
well i'm engaged to phil graham and he
comes by and picks me up
and we talk things over and that helps a
lot so i just said oh
and then he they broke up and he went
out with a friend of mine called alice
barry
and she said did i know phil
i said no i didn't she said you should
he's just the greatest here
and i said oh
and then about new year's
um
my sister gave a party and invited
everybody at the house where they were
then living and there were 12 and
and he was in the party and we first got
to know each other that way
and this developed rather quickly
because the third time we went out
together
he discussed marriage
third time the third time and how much
later did you marry him
well i said we this was a little hasty
or not but i was really intrigued by the
idea
but i said we had to be very deliberate
and wait a month
and i think we hardly did wait a month
and we were married that june
the
he was working for justice supreme court
justice stanley reed
and he was going to clerk for justice
frankfurter the next year so when the
court adjourned we were married june 5th
1940.
and both justice reed and frankfurter
were at the wedding they were
what one of them the best man
no no
justice frankfurter
was how close to you and your husband as
during those years
he was a mentor to phil
who had gotten to know him when he was
still at the harvard law school
and who chose the first five clerks from
the law school boys he knew
of which phil was one
and um
he would i had known him because my
parents were friends of his too but i
didn't know him well
and that year we really became great
friends
and he was simply wonderful to us
and
he was so funny
and so
intimate he he he liked the boys to
argue with him and
particularly his law clerks where they
were if they didn't agree with him
they would all indulge in screaming
fights up to my kind of i was shocked by
some of their manners but he liked this
confrontation
and he liked to discuss issues like that
and he was wonderful to me and to us
and both he and mrs frankfurter who
became a friend too
were very very close to us
how many children did you and phil
graham have
we had four we have i have four
my oldest is elizabeth weymouth who was
a journalist of
uh and writes for the post and on
foreign affairs but other things too
known as lally known as lowly
donald who was
chief executive officer of the company
william called bill
who has an investment partnership in los
angeles but who lives on the vineyard in
the summer and is
very interested and loves the vineyard
and lives next door to me with his
children and i love that and stephen
who is married and lives in new york
and is getting a postgraduate degree in
in literature and is in teaching but he
has been in the theater
and has produced and and has an
experimental theater going
you lost a son though i lost our first
baby which was
tremendously traumatic
who was born full term but um
because it was in washington during at
the beginning of the war and the
hospitals were very busy
and it was an it was
an accidental thing in the hospital it
really shouldn't have happened
and phil went in the army right
afterwards so it was pretty devastating
yes what impact did it have on you
you remember
well it was just awful because i thought
phil was going in the army it was the
end of everything we'd never have any
children something might happen to him
um it was a pretty awful moment
how long did you how long did phil
graham's been in the
in the army
well he went in and
it was two and a half years i think
when did he go to work for the post
my father talked to him when he was in
officer's school
he had by this time invested heavily of
both
financial resources and energy and and
effort in building up the post and it
was very discouraging because they were
losing money every year and he was
making progress of great guides
both in circulation and to some extent
in advertising but it just looked
terribly discouraging
and he wanted to make sure that
um
he had a successor in place that there
was some point to all this work and my
brother was
was by then a psychiatrist and was
interested in medicine
and so he asked phil if he'd be
interested and we had long talks about
it and i said he had to decide
and he did
finally and he said what did i think and
i said well i loved washington but i was
willing he wanted originally to go into
law and politics in florida and um
his half-brother being senator bob
graham that is true and bob did just
what phil
kind of aspired to
and that's nice
i think he's a great
and very fine senator how many years was
phil graham the publisher
17
and during that time
he became publisher
when he was not quite 31
because my father
he went on the post right after
he got back and we had terminal leave it
was january 46
and
six months later my father was offered
to be president of the world bank by
president truman and he said to phil i
won't leave if you don't want me to but
this is kind of my first love because
that was the kind of thing he'd done for
the government
and he thought somebody ought to start
the world bank
and phil said no that was all right he
should do what he wanted to do
and so my father did that a name phil
publisher
so he
took up the struggle
and from 47 to 54 he too had the same
kind of time really really difficult
time
and in 54 my father who had come back
from the world's bank where the world
bank actually six months after he went
because he did get it started and he did
get the regulations changed that made
him
really frustrated
and he felt that he couldn't do any more
than he'd done at his age
and so he had resigned and come back but
he left phillips publisher
the last time we had our cameras in
robert mcnamara's office he told me that
the desk that he uses is your father's
desk when he was the first head of the
world bank
he did he had this great big heavy kind
of wonderful desk
um
and he left it
to the back because i guess it was huge
and kind of
cumbersome and he left it there
and bob inherited it i believe
took it with him did he to his own
office his own office yes
uh the reason i bring it up is that
you're still close friends with bob
mcnamara today i am
he's a good friend did he serve on the
board eventually yes he did
yeah
you have devote a lot of time in here to
your
husband your deceased husband
had the story about his death ever been
told in the detail that you told it
not cohe coherent not consecutively
i think most of what i told had been
here and there
had you it was it hard for you to do
that retell that story rethink it relive
it
it wasn't even easy and not only because
of the sensitivity of what i was writing
but because
um i wanted to be sure to put it in
context it was a comparatively short
period in which he was
in which he was finally very ill and
did some quite aberrational things
and
that most of our life together was
wonderful and that he was wonderful
and i didn't want
the bad part at the end to overshadow
the very very good part and i wanted to
tell one of the reasons i wrote this
book was to say how great he was and my
parents were each
in their own way i thought there were
three people who deserved
to be remembered and and to be written
about
what were the circumstances of his death
he was subject to manic depressive
illness before
lithium
i think it was being experimented with
but it certainly wasn't being used
and he went to a psychiatrist who didn't
believe in drugs of any kind or electric
shock or anything
and so phil himself didn't because of
the psychiatrist and because he natively
thought it left you not as
as
human as you had been
that it affected your mind
and so he didn't want i i don't think
there were any much was available but he
didn't want it either
and
so he essentially suffered from
untreated manic depression
at the end he went off with a young
woman
a researcher at newsweek whom he met
and very quickly picked up and took up
with
and
it was
finally after some hesitations and backs
and forth
he left with her and said that what was
the matter with him was me and that he
wanted a divorce and he was going to
keep the paper and
and he was going to marry her
and then
as i kind of thought might happen
because
this was pretty spectacular as you can
imagine in 62.
was it public yes
of course it finally had to be
it wasn't for at first
but we had successfully hidden his
illness which had really started getting
serious in 1957 and from then on the
cycles were
getting closer and and worse
but people didn't know about it until
this very public event happened and so
they thought well this this is what
happens sometimes and he they didn't
realize
i even said to one friend you know he's
ill
and she said don't say that everybody
says that when their husband leaves them
and
uh
so i realized that i'd better not say
that but i knew that this was part of it
and um
he got depressed
in the summer of that year in july
and 1962 1963 53 yes because jack
kennedy was killed in november and you
were all close well not close but they
were they were friends
and
phil knew the president pretty well and
i
i knew of them too
and we did see something of him
and
he was also good friends with the vice
president
and
um so
he came home
and
asked the girl to go back home
and
he came back to us
but he was so ill and so depressed and i
had seen him through
two of these depressions and i just felt
unequal to doing it again and
he was asked to and voluntarily did go
to a hospital from which he
succeeded in getting a day off during
which he killed himself
now
you uh talk about your life together and
all the people you knew but i guess it
was that the moment in the eisenhower
administration where your husband
was actively involved in the civil
rights movement in in influencing the
the arkansas situation
central high school yes he had gotten
he'd gotten involved a little bit
i think he was
very he felt very southern
and
he
was very involved in
civil rights and in civil liberties
and
actually in 1957
um
he had
become involved with
the then majority leader lyndon johnson
in passing the 1957
civil rights law
and he had very much helped him get that
law passed
by talking to joe rau
and the naacp
and
by
telling them that the voting there were
no voting rights in act and it it was
i mean there were voting rights and not
school desegregation
and there was a jury
regulation in it that
you could appeal to a jury which at that
time were largely white so it was a very
weak civil rights law but it was the
first one in about 84 years
and phil persuaded joe rao who persuaded
the naacp
to accept this and that's the way it got
passed he also was the first chairman of
comsat yes
and
during
actually
during the eisenhower period which he
referred to
he had become
involved in the desegregation of the
little rock school
and he wanted to prevent eisenhower's
sending the troops in there
and um
he worked very hard and
somewhat frantically
to try to get everybody together and get
the school desegregated
and when it failed which it was going to
because governor forbes was standing
firm against the idea of de-school
desegregation
um
i think it threw him into his first
depression in 1957 actually
the reason i mentioned the comsat thing
what is your opinion today about how
involved people in the media ought to be
with the government i see you were
talking about just before he died he was
head of the communications satellite
incorporated
and um
he was head of that
and he was a half government half
governor and half private and yet he's
maintained his role as publisher i think
that's really uh not what anybody would
dream of doing these days
and before that he was heavily involved
in politics and involved with lyndon
johnson and involved as you said with um
little rock
and involved actually i tell a story
about desegregation of the of the swing
rules in washington which he
kept a story out of the paper and made a
deal with
um this interior department that if he
quieted the story of a riot that had
taken place about
the swimming pools that they would
desegregate them well that was using the
paper and influencing the news
and i think that's unacceptable these
days and
because you have to influence events by
telling giving people information by
which they can make decisions
and so
i think it wouldn't happen today
you wrote on page 140 you said it wasn't
until years later that i looked at the
downside of all this and realized that
perversely i had seemed to enjoy the
role of doormat wife for whatever reason
i like to be dominated and to be the
implementer
i meant that just the way it's written
i didn't feel put upon and i adored our
life i liked
being what i called the chief operating
officer i did everything at home i kept
the houses running i took care of the
children i made the decisions about
summers
i bought and sold houses and moved
i did everything that most families i
think share because he was so
working so hard and i knew i was trying
to take the pressure off by doing
everything at home
and
i was interested in our life i was
interested in meeting the people we met
i adored
the family
i don't
know that i saw myself
the way people would view that situation
now in which you really were brought up
to think that men were intellectually
superior
and that you've kind of lived
intellectually often which is of course
ridiculous
even you can work or not work these days
women have choices that's the main point
but you have to have your own identity
in your own interests
you uh point out in the book that he's
buried literally right across the street
from where you live that's true how did
that happen
in a really weird way because the
cemetery is a perfectly beautiful
cemetery
across the street
oak hill
and
um there weren't many places in its very
old cemetery
and
he got kind of interested in having a
plot there for us
and
it was kind of like getting into a club
or something
our great friends the bruces and the
john walkers and the atchisons and
people we knew all had these plots there
and he made jokes about this and said we
should be sandwiched in there somewhere
and
one day he came home from a school
meeting
and said well i've got
this plot because i've become acquainted
with somebody on the same old school
board and we can get in
and it became a family kind of joke
and he even made lugubrious jokes about
you can just wheel me across the street
i mean
you know when with what happened of
course it's it's appalling but um
you never thought of it as a reality
and so
we were at the church at the funeral and
my children one of my sons and
other people had made the arrangements
so i had no idea that this plot was
literally across the street from the
house in front of the little chapel
and i was pretty startled when we
arrived there after the service
to find that it was right there in front
of my eyes
and at first it bothered me but now i
really like it
and you've lived in that house
for the last 34 years 50.
and you've never
remarried
no but we learned in the book that
you've had some suitors like adlai
stevenson
at one point well i'd
you know i had friends let's put it that
way
has it been hard to be in a job like
yours
and
resist the you know the attention you
would get from men
actually no
because
i really worked terribly hard and i
moved around where i had to
and i led a life that was
really essentially work even if i went
out in the evening it was either
something i had to do or really did want
to do or i stayed home
and
i i don't think there was room in that
life to get married to anybody that was
very strong and wanted me to
be there more than i was
so it really never came up as a
practical
fact
after your husband shot himself how long
was it before you took over the post
i went away for a
month and came back and went to work but
that wasn't to say i took over the post
i went to work to learn the issues
i didn't really see myself as taking
over the post but i did go to work right
away
and gradually
i learned that you couldn't sit there
studying the thing
and i was encouraged to by some of the
executives and mainly by um fritz
frederick bibi who was
whom phil had made the chairman who had
been our corporate lawyer
and
he said you have to come to work
and i was happy to do that
because i cared a great deal about the
company and about the post which i'd
lived a struggle for its existence had
been part of my whole life
and i knew what had gone into making it
as successful as it even was which was
still
competitive
and
so
gradually
having gone to work to learn
fritz b i worked with him and
worked as president of the company
and
i became publisher when john swederman
who had been published made publisher by
phil left
and
then fritz died 10 years later just
after we'd go in public
and so then i became head then i did
take over the company you call 1971 and
1976 the turbulent years
why
well because rapidly we went through the
pentagon papers
and watergate
and just as i thought things had calmed
down
we went through a very violent pressman
strike in 75 so
those
those were three really cosmic events
and
that happened and and in public so to
speak
the the pentagon papers chapter when
you're reading that i wrote some some
names back down the back because
there's so many people that people have
heard of were involved at one time
i wanted to see if you can explain it
people have been in the government and
out in law firms and out and i just want
to know how you kept all these people
straight
for instance you had
your lawyer at one time was bill rogers
who had become secretary of state
yes at the time of the pentagon papers
in other words you would no
he wasn't your lawyer then but he was
secretary of state but he had been your
lawyer yes right paul ignatius was was
he president of your company
yes and he had been secretary of the
navy yes but he was at your company then
roswell kilpatrick played a role
somewhere in your company roz was not
was a he was in a involved with us as a
law partner in crevath
and before that he'd been in the
government was he deputy yeah and then
he went out he was on our yes he was
deputy's
defense secretary and ed williams had
edward bennett williams had been your
husband's attorney
when he was
when he was thinking he wanted a divorce
divorce and take some of your money and
go the other way and then you ended up
leaning on him at the time
we became very close friends and then he
came in as a lawyer
later actually with fritz bb and i
brought him in together
and
bob mcnamara was at scottie wrestling's
home
the night of the pentagon papers was
published in the new york times and he
asked him advice as you pointed out in
your book here and he's told the same
story here and in addition to that
scottie restaurant was a very close
friend of yours yes who ran the new york
times washington bureau to try to get to
work for you i guess that when i was
reading this i just said and then ben
beg dickie and was your national editor
who you went on not to think so highly
of later on in your book as i remember
critical of the post later okay anyway
the pentagon papers how do you do how do
you deal in a town like this when one
day somebody's your lawyer the next day
and then the government
and you stay packed but everybody else
stay put everybody else is moving around
you ever get confused
no because um once people are in the
government the relationship changes and
you can be friends with people in the
government but you have they remember
and you remember the paper comes first
and sometimes the paper attacks your
friends or does things even that you
think are unfair to your friends
and
sometimes you can reason with the
editors but
mostly you have to just stand by them
when you travel and as you go around
talking to people on the book tour and
you've lived in sioux city if i remember
right
sioux falls you live in chicago you live
in san francisco where else any other
cities for very long
not much it's really washington most of
the time
but what i was getting at is people look
at the post and they look at washington
and they just
you know they're cynical about all the
power and the control and and how do you
how do you tell them about the
you know the folks that are way away
from here saying you don't have too much
power
i try to explain what the power of a
newspaper or magazine or television
stations are
for instance the post has the power
to
inform people
and where they play a story
matters probably if they cover it well
it matters because you're talking to the
government as well as people in
washington
but you don't have the power they
sometimes people think you run
downstairs and talk to editors you don't
i mean about a story in particular you
never see stories before they get in the
papers
you have the power to pick an editor you
think
or a publisher or whatever it is
that will do the job well and that is in
your general mold of thought
but after that they really have autonomy
and
so you don't have the power to
i mean that people envision you as
having
of making or breaking
people or influencing events directly
you have more it sounds like goody two
shoes but you have more responsibility
than power
you wrote on page 360 you say that the
news columns had to be fair and detached
even while recognizing that there really
is no such thing as objectivity
detached is the word that i think is
better because
an objectivity the way most people
interpret it you can have but
uh
you exercise an an editor exercising
a judgment when you just think what is
relevant you have to make selections of
what goes into the paper and what
doesn't so that's what i mean by there
is no
there's no such thing as objectivity
because the human being does that
and you do it the best you can to be
fair and detached and and accurate
but you are making a human judgment and
there was a person making it that's all
i mean i wanted to
do you remember the first person you
personally had to fire
and what the experience was like
i do but i don't want to talk about it
but you talk about a lot of people in it
i mean
i talk about it in the book but he was a
dear friend and it was very painful phil
jalen
no al friendly
is al friendly's grandson over working
for bill clinton yes andrew andrew yeah
he's the guy that's with him all the
time
here's what i want to ask you about
you talk to me is it peter is it darrow
darrell
he said that he felt i was hopelessly
and
hopelessly an adequate leader and that
he had little choice but to leave for
the dynamic cbs he touched a raw
sensitivity when he assaulted me for not
being a professional manager and i must
confess that i wept on and off for at
least two days
mortifying but why did you admit all
this
and and what was the circumstances
i really don't know maybe i shouldn't
have
but i tend to be
upfront and honest so i guess i just
told it the way it happened he was how
he was when was he when was peter duro
there
with you and what job did he have
um
he was
um i know i forget his actual title he
was the running
he was first he was number two
business person at newsweek and he then
actually after that incredible scene
he came back from cbs and ran the
business side of newsweek and he
actually told you to your face that he
thought you were doing a lousy job yup
but then you go on about 20 pages later
and you say to add to my anxieties
during this difficult period peter dero
told me he found another job he he left
you and told you he didn't like what you
did and you brought him back
yes
why
i can't answer that i don't know okay
but later he said he
he was uh it seemed like the thing to do
at the time but it was it wasn't a good
idea then he was going he went back to
cbs and then he came to you again and he
had a chat he said he was quite willing
to start in again on what was wrong with
me and the company but by this time i
had grown tougher and told him that once
was enough it seemed to irritate him not
to be able to to repeat the monologue
on my failings
how do what toughened you up
time
and experience
and and to what purpose did all that did
you put that to once you toughened up
well
i think i could make decisions better
and
and more firmly
and
stick by them and not quite ask so much
advice
you say that when you although i think
you always ask some advice
you say that when you first got
to the post and were in charge that that
you were petrified about speaking
couldn't open my mouth
i had to practice in front of the
children the first year
i was
working at the paper
i was asked to go down and say merry
christmas to the company lunch
and i literally my children are
hilarious they keep telling the story
i practice making this speech saying
merry christmas
in front of the children
because i'd never said anything in
public to even my children lined up in a
row
what moment do you remember where you
had to make the most important speech
well i made a lot of speeches defending
us during watergate i guess that's when
i started really speaking the most
and
i was trying to explain that we were
reporting a story and that we weren't
after the administration and that we
weren't it wasn't our intention to do
them in that we were following the
footsteps of the story
and so i started speaking quite a lot
that year 72 70 well probably
later 73 and 4.
in that short time remaining let me ask
you about presidents because there are
pictures in here with you with every
president since london johnson
john kennedy what do you think of john
kennedy
i found it irresistibly
charming attractive
um
and it was awfully exciting having
someone you knew as president
uh having your generation in the white
house and having these young people
there i thought they were admirers how
is he today in retrospect
well i think that he did turn things
around and excited people
but in the three years he had before he
died i don't think he had the chance to
really get an awful lot done of what he
was trying to do
i think that president johnson succeeded
him and got legislation passed
that he wanted to get done but didn't
lyndon johnson undressed in front of you
one night
well that was another
quite funny story because i was at his
34th wedding anniversary
and
just as we were he was in a pretty bad
mood anyway
it was during the vietnam war
and
afterwards we went upstairs and he just
went to bed and left us and
his bedroom oddly was right next door to
the upstairs living room the yellow room
and there were some double doors between
and suddenly he came out we were saying
good night to mrs johnson and the doors
were flung open and he came out and said
come here and i looked
over my shoulder hoping somebody was
there but he was saying it to me
and then he said come here to abe fortis
who was then i believe on the supreme
court
and um
we went into his bedroom
and the post was lying on the bed
and
to
a man called to briner was the chief
commissioner in the district with still
three
but he was kind of like the appointed
mayor
and he we had been forming it back to
him so he was our from the johnson point
of view it was our creation
and
he had appointed a police commissioner
without consulting the president which
he had told him to do
and he was very displeased because he
wanted to prove something about being
anti-crime by appointing a super police
commissioner so he was really mad that
briner had gone ahead and done this and
he started yelling at me about our
goddamn mayor and he was this idea and
it was our fault he'd appointed this man
hadn't asked him when he you kind of
consulted him and he wanted to do it
and he started to undress
and i
i mean i was this is 64 please
and i was new to the job i'd only gone
to work and he's flinging his clothes
off while he's balling me out
and i thought wait a minute what is
going to happen here can this be me am i
standing here in the president's bedroom
and what is going to happen he suddenly
said turn around
and so i turned around and went right on
and finally he said all right good night
and
abe and i both left
and i mean it was quite a beginning
richard nixon
i never knew him really
um personally
uh i
met him and i talked to him and i even
interviewed him on and he came to lunch
at the paper an editorial lunch
so i saw him a little bit
but i didn't really know him personally
and
i think that he had many good traits i
think he was a real jekyll hyde
character because he had all these
things that we see keep seeing coming
out on the tapes and this really low
level side to him but he was really
brilliant in many many ways and he had
very many good people working for him i
i really view him with ambivalence
ronald reagan
well now there was another friend and
nancy especially i was new before they
were in the white house i think you
never get to be friends with a president
if you don't know them before
because their power is so great and they
see people as
as strangers so um i thought he was
he was a leader he we knew what he stood
for
i think he was very dignified man
i wasn't particularly i didn't agree
with him or all that he did
but nancy was a good friend and still is
bill clinton
i think this well now we're starting on
a second term and
um with both
its promises and its failures
um i'm very hopeful that things are
going to go well and i certainly hope
they do and think that they're many good
signs you say you don't see much of him
you haven't well again he's another
generation
they're very polite and we're not and i
i've seen them a little bit and we have
a mutual friend vernon jordan through
whom i've seen them a little bit
but there's no reason that i should see
them
toughest part of writing your book
it was all
sort of tough because i'm not a
professional writer
and yet i really didn't want to write it
with a writer because i thought that
i would get too jumpy and want to tell
them what to do too much and so i
thought i'd try to do it myself so it
was really hard just to do it where did
you write it
at home on my desk and and
i wrote it by hand
by hand yes
no then what'd you do with it after you
wrote it out i gave it to my researcher
who put it on a computer and put it all
in order and helped me
shape it and helped me make chapters of
it
and helped me get it together very he
was fairly essential and then we sent it
off to the editor who left half of it on
the cutting room floor that's what i
wanted to ask you next it's 625 pages if
they put it all in that you wrote
i think it might have been 1200
is there a second book to this thing no
that's it are you looking forward to
your tour around the country
sort of
would you
what do you think of the talking part of
this
it's hard for me
it's much harder than having written it
why i don't know why but your voice and
your
and talking about it in public
uh i find very hard and i'm not very
good at it either
as you can now see
catherine graham is our guest
and the book is called personal history
thank you very much
and tomorrow an encore q a with
washington post reporter david finkel on
his book thank you for your service